son más de 2000 casillas precarias
habitadas por unas 600 familias en 100
hectáreas la toma de tierras en la
localidad de guernica es la más grande
actualmente en la provincia de buenos
aires
para muchos de ellos estas
construcciones de chapa y madera son su
única vivienda
aunque no es un fenómeno nuevo la
ocupación de terreno se agravó por la
crisis del cob y 19
en la provincia de buenos aires desde el
inicio de las restricciones en marzo se
han producido 868 desalojos y 524
personas fueron detenidas lo mismo
hubiera ocurrido en gernika pero la
justicia postergó la medida para el
primero de octubre plazo en el que el
gobierno regional prometió reubicar a
los ocupantes más vulnerables
estimaciones de la universidad católica
argentina señalan que la pobreza en el
país subió del 40 al 45 o 46 por ciento
por la pandemia y la indigencia se elevó
del 7 al 10 por ciento lo que nosotros
calculamos que se puede haber perdido
cerca de un millón de puestos de trabajo
y mayoritariamente es ese proveniente de
lo que son el sector más precario del
mercado de trabajo según los vecinos de
la zona los terrenos están abandonados
desde hace 40 años la principal
demandante de la toma es una firma
inmobiliaria que impulsa la construcción
de un barrio privado toda una paradoja
emblema de la crisis habitacional
histórica en buenos aires